what's going everyone in this video i'm
going to talk about why i think
self-care is absolute nonsense and why
you should run the other way from
anybody who's telling you otherwise and
if you don't know who i am my name is
alex mosey on acquisition.com got some
new swag and i have nothing to sell you
we run a portfolio of 100 million
companies that make all the money and it
doesn't matter anyways so purpose of
this video like i said all this
self-care hoodoo nonsense gets people in
a lot of trouble and the reason for that
is because we think that for some reason
we are doing something wrong when we are
not self caring because it is bad too
not self-care because we should we must
or else or what and the reason this
pisses me off the reason that i made a
tweet that went viral um this morning
about this is that weekends are new for
humans they're not even 100 years old
1929 in england is when the first
weekend got passed by a union and it's
because people hated what they were
doing for their life and so if you want
to truly give self-care then stop hating
what you do every day novel concept i
know stop hanging out with people that
[ __ ] suck mind-blowing like i said i
know and the reason that i am so
passionate about this is that i have
been told throughout my entire life that
i was working too much i was not
balancing the things that i was supposed
to be balancing and you know what who
gives a [ __ ] it's my life i don't need
to live by anyone else's rules and
neither do you right and so when people
say you should be doing this you are not
doing xyz just take a pause and be like
are these rules that i want to listen to
are those your rules that you're trying
to apply to my life because there are no
rules you can do whatever the hell you
want if you want to work for a year
straight work for a year straight and
the reason you can work for a year
straight is because you like what you do
the reason these people try and project
their own self-hatred for their own
lives onto you is because they cannot
imagine a world in which someone might
actually like what they do every day and
didn't don't need an escape a break from
what their existence is on a daily basis
and so don't feel guilty for just being
you and if you don't like your life
every day rather than try and figure out
and make time for self-care it would
probably be better to flip the ratio and
start thinking what can i do in my
actual life to stop hating it so much
that i need an escape from it right and
that's different from like yes you need
to sleep yes you need to you know rest
etc but there's a difference between
that and like oh i just need a total spa
day and if that's how you relax cool but
the thing is is projecting on someone
else how they should must need to have
to relax or do whatever it's nonsensical
it doesn't exist right i wanted to make
this video even though it's short
because i it just drives me bananas if
you want to work work if you want to
take off take off just don't listen to
what anyone else says about what you
should do for your life you're going to
die and so will they and it's not going
to matter and in 10 generations don't
even remember your name so do what you
want you're going to die and that is the
ultimate freedom and for some reason we
live under these chains that we think
exist but don't and so i think the
process of of growing and really making
ourselves free is just simply
identifying the things that don't really
exist and only existed in our mind to
begin with and i think that's why
self-crit really bugs the [ __ ] out of me
or this whole self-care movement it's
also soft as [ __ ] like just work right
to get it done you need to like give
yourself a [ __ ] bubble bath every day
because like you're worked so hard like
human's been here a very long time we've
dealt with much much harder [ __ ] your
you know boss having a deadline the next
day is not the worst [ __ ] that you've
been through and so as a final sign off
on this think about the hardest things
that you've been through in your life
everyone has gone through hard [ __ ]
everyone has had difficulties in
childhood everyone has had difficulties
with siblings with parents blah blah
blah these events that shape our lives
you have been through harder [ __ ] than
this you will survive it will be okay
you don't need to self-care you don't
need to listen to what anyone else is
saying you do you and if that means
self-care by all means but just don't
project to anyone else alright lots of
love bozination see you guys in the next
video bye